nous sommes la stylisation des déchets
et il ne faut absolument pas que les
milieux vivants sur lesquels nous
comptons pour notre avenir soit détruits
ou abîmés par ces déchets
la civilisation des déchets au milieu
des années 60
alain bombard biologiste spécialiste du
monde marin tiré la sonnette d alarme
les déchets déversés dans la mer sont
une bombe à retardement pour l'espèce
humaine
cette pollution sera incontrôlable même
si ce qu'il a faux affirme et croit que
le produit qu'ils resteront dans la mer
sera constant et ne changera jamais
n'avons aucune certitude selon bon bah
si la mer est polluée c'est tout
l'approvisionnement des hommes qui en
sera affecté en poissons bien sûr mais
pas seulement
nous luttons contre la pollution de la
frange littorale et la pollution
générale des eaux ces eaux parce que
plus tard
cette eau de mer trop douce défendre les
océans c'est défendre la vie tel est le
message qu alain bombard répète
inlassablement sur les plateaux de
télévision avec une note d'espoir en
direction des jeunes générations
maintenant c'est vraiment le problème de
la défense des océans contre les hommes
et pour les hommes
les enfants sont très sensibles au fait
qu' il arrive dans un monde terriblement
abîmée par la civilisation des paroles
d'une étonnante actualité alors que la
problématique écologique est désormais
au coeur du débat public
les jeunes générations se montre
particulièrement sensible à la défense
de l'environnement
[Musique]